an important point
on our afghan allies what a lot of the
talk that you're hearing from
left-wingers and neo-liberals and and
the kind of squish conservative types
the
they call them neo-cons or the
imperialist types the ones who wanted to
stay in the middle east forever and
continue to bomb various muslim
countries and spread liberal democracy
all over the world you're hearing a lot
of talk about
our afghan allies
i'm going to take you on a little trip
down memory lane about our afghan allies
okay because i don't know that we can
really know who our afghan allies are
okay i appreciate people who have helped
the united states out over the years
there
in 1983 ronald reagan welcomed a group
of mujahideen afghan freedom fighters to
the oval office he
pointed out that these freedom fighters
were fighting the soviet union and said
the united states was going to support
them
the united states funneled a lot of
money to these mujahideen freedom
fighters over the years in in no small
part through the inter-services
intelligence agency which is a sort of
state within a state in pakistan so
through the isi
and also in other ways we start funding
the mujahideen freedom fighters the
mujahideen freedom fighters defeat the
soviet union the soviet union leaves and
the
soviet union collapses shortly
thereafter at that point believe it or
not all these various mujahideen groups
all of these various islamist groups
that fought the soviets the godless
atheist soviets turns out they weren't
so great at forming a government
together so that plunges afghanistan
into four more years of civil war during
that civil war there were various groups
and even though there were three four
than five groups it it turned out that
some of the people fighting didn't think
that was enough militants in the
conflict so they formed another group
that other group is called the taliban
they did that with the funding of
the isi and with the encouragement of
pakistan's isi okay
the taliban quickly all of the
not all but virtually all of the
taliban's original leadership by the way
were people that the united states had
funded in the original fight against the
soviets okay taliban takes over
afghanistan starts to rise during the
early 1990s and then 1996 declares the
islamic emirate of afghanistan okay they
rule for about five years they they with
the support of our allies in the isi
harbor osama bin laden osama bin laden
al-qaeda osama bin laden al qaeda attack
the united states on september 11th the
united states goes in and deposes the
taliban the taliban then goes out and
retreats we obviously stay there for
about 20 years now
the taliban is coming back into control
so that they they were our allies in our
enemy they were sort of our allies then
our enemy then our allies again now we
get attacked by isis isis is a rival
islamic terror group they just attacked
us in kabul they're fighting against the
taliban now
they attacked us because the security in
kabul wasn't good enough the security in
kabul had been
given to the haqqani network as i just
mentioned the haqqani network was one of
the largest recipients of cia funding
during the cold war so then the kakani
network turned against us the isi and
the cia were funding the haqqani network
until the isi started paying the haqqani
network to attack the cia are you still
following me because i'm not i can't
follow me anymore because it's so damn
confusing you've got the afghan national
army which the united states had been
funding for 20 years that's the one that
just collapsed when the taliban walked
in but even the afghan national army
first of all was largely comprised or
it largely comprised fake soldiers ghost
soldiers who just existed on paper so
that people could get paid but they
weren't real people in real life there
was a
report from the special inspector
general for afghanistan reconstruction
it showed that 50 to 75 percent of
afghan national army soldiers were high
on drugs a lot of the time when they
weren't high on drugs they were offering
stealing things and in some cases
especially in 2012 they were killing our
own soldiers and their fellow afghan
national army soldiers
there was also we talk about how awful
it is that there are new sexual crimes
being perpetrated by the taliban as they
take over kabul well it turns out the
afghan national army the good guys our
allies were perpetrating huge amounts of
sexual violence through a practice
called baccabazi this was ritual called
boy play it was ritual pederastic abuse
of young boys there were well over 5000
reported incidents of this just to the
oversight authorities and almost
certainly the problem was much more
widespread than that so please please
when you're telling me about what we
should do in afghanistan please spare me
the sanctimony over our allies because
we have no idea who our allies are
because there are no allies in
afghanistan which is not a country
it's not a nation
and our allies change by the day
sometimes by the hour
so yes we all want to evacuate people
who are good guys who are on our side
who help us out and who want a vision of
the world that we do
but that's changed a lot over the years
okay
and i think this is what people's
exasperation with our foreign policy in
afghanistan is that we have no idea what
we want because it became
one initially it was this attack to go
kill the terrorists who took down the
towers then it became this this crusade
for nation building and spreading
liberal democracy and abolishing tyranny
from the world those are george w bush's
words
and then it became what about sending
girls to school or something and that's
why we're going to keep our guys in
harm's way
what is it what is it a sensible foreign
policy asks
basic questions
what do we want to have happened there
now what do we stand to gain from it
how much are we willing to lose
that's what we have to ask and all of
this clap trap
about our allies the wonderful amazing
out no look
there are no allies there are interests
in afghanistan okay
and
the longer it takes us to learn that
lesson the worse off we're going to be
hold up hold up
all right i'm glad you like that video
that's that makes me feel very good if
you want to leave me a little comment
about it that would make me feel even
better i need you to subscribe both here
on youtube and
apple podcast spotify stitcher google
play really helps to avoid some of the
big tech issues that we've had in some
i'm not blaming anybody but sometimes
they don't like what we say if you go on
over to apple podcast spotify stitch
your google play the michael knowles
show subscribe leave a five star review
see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you